an influential transgender group is
advising that children as young as 14
can be given sex change drugs by doctors
if they're seeking to change their
gender it's one of the recommendations
by an influential organization that
writes the guidelines of care for
transgender people worldwide the
suggestion though has sparked a fiery
backlash
14 is no age to be making such huge
irreversible decisions i do not think
anyone that age is able to give proper
informed consent to take cross-sex
hormones and 15 is much too young to
have a double mastectomy when you can't
have a tattoo in the uk until you're 18.
apart from green lighting sex change
treatment for 14 year olds another tip
from the transgender group is to allow
15 year olds to undergo chest
masculinization surgery the organization
says that age bar is being suggested due
to concerns of potential side effects
like weaker bones and psychosocial
problems if procedures are carried out
later in life they also admit though
that evidence on effective early medical
intervention is limited
we spoke to an american author who
underwent gender reassignment and lived
as a woman for eight years before
de-transitioning walt heyer thinks there
needs to be caution when dealing with
sex change therapies for children
my opinion is you should not give any
child
hormones
or help them transition just because
they think they're transgender it's
important for them to confirm
that they are not dealing with some
underlying comorbidity like body
dysmorphia dissociative disorder they
don't have the capability
to understand the long-term consequences
of taking such
drugs and their serious
steroid drugs that they're using we're
beginning to destroy an entire
generation of children what we need to
understand though is very critical
for us to have a discussion about the
fact that
what this is is the deconstruction
of our children in other words when they
start engaging in this idea of
transgender and they're actually
deconstructing and dehumanizing who they
are steroids are very addictive
they become accustomed to taking the
hormones are addictive and they become
accustomed to taking them what i find in
my website sex change regret is they
contact me years later wanting to get
their life back because they really
weren't
transgender they really shouldn't have
taken the hormones and nobody prevented
them from it so i work to help them get
their life back